I'm Mike Beals and I'm Assistant Scoutmaster with Troop 226 in Roswell, Georgia.
This edition of the Scoutmaster Podcast is sponsored by backers like me.
And now for you, Scoutmaster.
Um, listen, uh, I had. I had planned on sharing a funny story about Eagle Projects,
but I haven't completed it yet. But don't worry, I have plenty of time. I really do.
I have plenty of time to get it done.
This is podcast number 261.. Hey,
Welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast. This is Clark Green.
So going right into the mailbag here, we heard from Cora Shahid who said:
this scouter is H-A-P-P-Y happy. Thank you, My app is fixed and I can listen to the podcast again.
Oh my, yes, Cora, Thank you for getting in touch and for being a bright spot in an otherwise
dark and difficult time with the Android version of the Scoutmaster CG app.
Now listen, if you've installed the Android version of the Scoutmaster CG app in the past,
what you're going to do is you need to uninstall it and install the new version,
which is now available on Google Play. I checked on it this morning again and there's lots of people
have been installing it and it seems to be working okay. but it's been a bit of a waking nightmare the
past week or so trying to get this fixed. So let me be very clear: The new app is what you want.
Uninstall the one that's not working. Install the new app. It works, And the good news,
the silver lining- in the cloud- is that it remains free because of the folks who become
scoutmastercgcom backers. Now, if you have the iTunes app, you're going to update it and you'll see
some changes, but you really don't have to do anything And really my heartfelt apologies to
those of you who have found that the Android app isn't working. It's taken way, way too long
to get fixed. by way of explanation, My old app provider wasn't taking care of business. They were
extraordinarily slow to respond to my cries for help a couple of weeks ago when the app was not working.
So I found a new app provider. We built a new app And, because this is not something that I do every
day, it's been a long and arduous process And the only way we could get the new app to you
was to get rid of the old one. Yai yai, yai, yai yai. I really appreciate your patience
And I understand why some of you have been a little impatient about it, because I certainly
have been. Now, if you encounter any problems with the app, email me. okay, Get in touch with me
at Clark at scoutmastercgcom, And I'll do my best to get it fixed. But as of this
announcement, I'm hoping that the majority of the problems are fixed. Oh please,
Oh my, we do have some fun, Yes, even in the midst of irksome tasks and weighty responsibilities.
So let's move on, shall we? We had some live chats this past week and the live chats happened
at scoutmastercgcom. There's a chat button in the lower right hand side. Normally, I'll
announce when we're going to be on for a live chat through my Facebook and Twitter feed, So
you want to make sure to check that out. And sometimes, if I'm working in my desk for a while,
I will turn the live chat on just to be available, and I won't necessarily make an
announcement on it. But in addition to all of our frequent fliers who show up for the chat,
we also chatted with Bruce Liggett in Billings, Montana, where he's an assistant scout master
for troop 10.. Jamie Jones, who is on the committee of troop 152 in Cuyahoga Falls, Ohio.
Vincent Arbug is the advancement chair and a chapter advisor for the Order of the Arrow in Iowa.
Jeff is an assistant scout master in Omaha, Nebraska. Mark Mills is from Madeleine, New Jersey,
and he's a newly minted assistant scout master for troop 66.. Leon Venedictu is in Richmond-
not in Virginia, but in the United Kingdom, in Great Britain- And he's an assistant scout
leader for the Scouts Association there and was a scout himself as a youth in Greece. David Wilkes
is in Dallas, Texas, and he's an assistant scout master for troop 68. And he's soon to become
the scout master. It looks like July, So welcome to the volcano, almost. David Dan Clegg is the
scout master of troop 460 in Orem, Utah. Kirk Seager is in Castlebury, Florida, where he's an
assistant scout master in troop 692.. Keep an eye on the Facebook and Twitter feeds for announcements
when we'll be having a live chat. It's mostly weekday mornings- And check in, say hi. Now,
before I get any further, let me tell you this: if the resources that we've created have helped
you, I need your help in return to keep them freely available to scouts just like you all
over the world. You know we had a problem with the Android app. I don't know if you
noticed, but we had a problem with it and we were able to get it fixed because we have
backers. You can go to scoutmastercgcom today and click the support link at the top of the page
and you'll learn exactly how this works. Backers make a one time voluntary subscription payment
to support what we're doing, And some levels of support earn a premium, like an autograph copy
of one of my books. So go to scoutmastercgcom, click the support link at the top of the
page, become a backer this week. And I want to take a moment to thank John Hartfig, Kelly
McKiernan, Terry Dutton, Jacques Navias, James Monteney, Michael Beals and Brad Chilcote
for becoming backers since our last podcast And for the third and last time. go to
scoutmastercgcom, click the support link, become a backer this week, and I'll be sure
to thank you on the next podcast. And a big thank you to all the backers who keep us up
and running. In this week's podcast, I have some email questions to answer, And in scout
master's ship in seven minutes or less, we're going to discuss the dreaded troop program death
spiral. sounds ominous, doesn't it? And that's going to take up the remainder of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we? scout master's ship in seven minutes or less?
Now, naturally, a title like troop program death spiral is a little gratuitously dramatic,
right, But it does describe something that I think does happen And it did get your
attention right. This is based on an article that I wrote a year or two ago and
reposted this past week on Facebook And it really struck a chord with folks, got a lot of
comments and a lot of likes and shares on Facebook I thought it would be good to talk
about. on the podcast I heard from Corey Needleman on Facebook. he said there has been some talk
amongst our adult leadership that you are monitoring and intercepting our electronic
communications and releasing podcasts or articles that are directly relevant to
current topics we're discussing. I hear that once in a while, Corey, And it is true
I have agents everywhere. Bob Deck also commented on it and he said it is the job of the adults
to guide the scouts, to direct them to wholesome activities where they can have fun and
adventure and learn, not to sit them in a classroom and teach them. The scouts should
be running almost everything, with the adults watching and giving guidance when needed,
And I wanted to thank also Megan Sandlin and Michael Gagney, Bill McFarland and John Nelson
for checking in with a big thumbs up on that post. Carrie Barclay brought up the other end
of the spectrum and she commented on a troop that loses scouts because they're not having
any fun or doing anything, because the adults are so hands off in the name of being youth led,
that nothing really happens. John Probst replied that, yeah, adult guidance is a must, but
some people seem to forget it, And I would agree. you know, scout led is not without context or guidance
from adults. It's not about adults doing nothing and accepting every decision or having zero
expectations of the scouts. Being youth led is not a slogan. It takes a lot of work and study to
get it right. So let's talk about how troops get off track and potentially lose scouts and
this crazy kind of troop program death spiral that I'm talking about. I think there's a predictable
sequence of events that lead to a spiral that can crash the entire troop program, And it's not
the scouts. right, Because the scouts will follow your lead. They're going to follow your lead
and they're going to adopt your attitude. It ends up being us. It's the adults who are
volunteering to be involved, And I think a lot of it comes from when we sign up to be adult
volunteers. We do one of two things: We attend training and then we go on to work at understanding
our role and we evaluate what's happening and we try and do it better and we learn more and we
gain more experience and we try and do it better. But we're always in this evaluating, looking at
what's going on mode. Hopefully that means that we don't get stuck in a rut and we have the
knowledge that we can get better in our roles. The other things that happens is a lot of adults
who volunteer don't get trained, And even those who go to training, if they don't learn the role
and ask questions and try and get better at it, they just end up following the breadcrumb trail
of bad practices that were present in the troop when they signed on. So either we take the time
to understand and study our role in scouting and follow those principles or we end up
perpetuating old mistakes. Now it's almost impossible to become a volunteer for a scout
troop without hearing at least something about the patrol method or the virtues of a scout-led troop.
So let's say you learn about the patrol method, you go ahead and apply it. Well,
when we apply the concepts and practices of the patrol method, the first results are almost
always disappointing from the adult perspective. That's important because it is a matter of
perspective To an adult scouts working at the patrol method for the first time
are going to look incapable and incompetent or even just lazy. Their efforts are going to be
disjointed and chaotic and they're going to fall far short of creating the kind of ideal
orderliness and efficiency that we imagine they can. Now, instead of looking at that state of affairs
as a positive indication of growing and developing leaders, this disappointment is looked at as a
failure of the patrol method as a way of doing things. And if adults become convinced that the
patrol method just won't work, then they take over and they run things in an efficient, orderly
manner, like adults do. right, Because when we adults run things there's less trouble,
there's less uncertainty. Scouts will be happy to have things taken care of
and they won't complain about it. Why would that? You know, boys are very sharp efficiency experts.
If an adult is willing to do everything for them, of course they're going to do it,
especially if they end up joining a troop where the adults do everything in the first place. It's
just the way things work. They don't have any experience, to the contrary, so why wouldn't
they follow along? And you know what Scouts will stay: an adult led troop where all the
decisions are being made by the adults, all plans are being made by the adults.
the adults cook all their meals for them, but they're only going to stay just so long because
they're going to get bored eventually. And unless the adults are able to come up with
more new and even more entertaining experiences, Scouts are going to get bored and they're going
to leave. And that's really upsetting to the volunteers who are putting all their time into
making this wonderful experience for the Scouts right. And you get resentful because you
think that the Scouts don't properly appreciate what's being done for them And this turns
into frustration and hardens into resentment And usually this results in the next curve of the
spiral, which is making rules. You know we're going to a lot of effort here to plan these
meetings and outings and things like that, And the boys aren't even showing up. So I know what
we'll do. Let's make some rules. If you can't be a scout in this troop unless you show up at
this percentage of meetings and outings, you must do this, you must do that. And that
kind of rulemaking is kind of hardening that resentment And it's likely to drive more Scouts
away And then we get into the next curve of the spiral. Adults get even more frustrated
that everything that they're doing and trying to make this work doesn't seem to be gaining any
traction. They're pretty fatigued from trying to hold things together and doing everything.
Things continue to spiral down And we lose adult volunteers and we lose Scouts And
ultimately we can lose the entire troop. So how do we not get into this spiral? Well,
first step is getting trained. but getting trained is not enough. We can't just get
trained and passively receive the ideas. We have to apply them. We have to test those ideas.
We have to pick them apart and learn about them. We have to go through a continuous process of
putting them into action and observing the results, assessing what we understand about them
and then trying all over again. One thing I'm fond of saying is that adults involved with a scout
troop need to have a very high tolerance for adversity and uncertainty, because Scouts
learn how to lead through experience. Those experiences, from an adult perspective, can be
very tiresome and difficult. So we need to, through training, through our own study,
through our own working at it, understand exactly what's going on. So the good news-
and all this is totally within our power to control as adult volunteers: Get trained,
understand your role. study it. Don't just passively receive what you get at training.
pick it apart, look at it, study it, read up, use the resources that are provided to us
and apply the patrol method and stick with it. Give it a chance to work. have a tolerance for
some uncertainty and some adversity. Work with your Scouts in it and you'll begin to reap
the benefits. Stick with the process, strive to understand it and you'll avoid the dreaded
Troop Program Death Spiral.
Write me a letter, send it by name Email, that is folks. And here's an answer to one of your emails.
I received this email from a long-time listener and reader who said
I have run into two problems related to the Eagle Scout application process
that I haven't run into before. They're both kind of complicated by adult politics and I'm
hoping you can help me out. Problem number one is a scout who came to my attention
who has some significant adverse events in his life around his border review for Eagle. The border
review was completed, he has all the paperwork but he wasn't given any instruction on what to do next,
and now several months have passed since his border review and he's kind of given up on his
application. How can I help him get this fixed. Well, that problem is probably reasonably easy
to fix, Even if we're past the 18th birthday. so long as everything for Eagle was completed,
including the border review, and he has a complete application, he should be able to submit that
application and get the Eagle recognition that he's earned. Now, exactly how that's going to
happen depends on a number of factors. So I would suggest that you get in touch with the folks
at advancementteam at scoutingorg. Advancementteam at scoutingorg. They're very responsive
and they'll be able to tell you how to salvage that application and get things figured out.
Problem number two is a scout who is the president for his venturing crew. but the crew adult
leadership is kind of disconnected and not helping him with his advancement to Eagle.
So he's also registered with a troop. He doesn't hold a position of responsibility in the troop.
so there's a question about who can sign off on the position of responsibility required for Eagle.
Must this be an adult leader in the venture crew or can his troops scout master- sign off
on a position of responsibility in a different unit? Well, I looked at the resources and I could
not find any restriction on who can sign off on the position of responsibility,
whether it has to be the unit leader where the scout holds a position of responsibility, or
there is no specific limitation that I have found, And if there was, I think it would be directly
there in the requirement or in the guide to advancement. And this sounds similar to an experience
that I had a year or so ago. We had a scout who came to us from another troop and I sat down
with him and had a scout master conference for the rank of life. Now he had not held
any position of responsibility in our troop, but he represented that he had in his old troop,
And so it took about four questions and about 10 minutes to figure this one out. I asked him
to give me some specific examples about how he fulfilled that position of responsibility.
I asked him to tell me what he had learned from it. I asked him about the particular
challenges or accomplishments he experienced in fulfilling that position and some very specific
things about when he did it and where he did it and how he did it. And I followed up by saying:
you know, before we signed this requirement one last time, on your honor as a scout,
you've accurately and completely answered all my questions, And if you have even the slightest
reservation that you've completed this requirement. we shouldn't sign it now And we should figure
out how you're going to complete it. But we both agreed that he had completed the requirement
and so I signed it off. Now, in the discussion that I had with him, if he wasn't able to
come up with any specific things or something seemed to be amiss, I may have gone further to see
if I could find any proof of what he had done by talking to his parents or his fellow scouts or
the leaders from his past troop. But you know, after we discussed things, I really didn't need to.
I was able to take him at his word and I don't regret doing so. I think it was the right
decision to have made. And in the course of that discussion, we found out why he left his
old troop. They were digging him for an attendance metric they had established and for you know
things like not having a complete uniform or missing meetings, And he was missing meetings
because he was involved in activities at school where he was exercising a lot of leadership skill.
Because of these perceived problems, he was turned back from getting a border review for life
several times over a two year period. There were some adult politics involved in this as
well, But, as I said, I haven't been able to find any restriction on who can sign that
requirement for Eagle. When we're dealing with the technicalities around advancement
and procedures and policies, the last thing I want you to do is take exactly what I say
as being gospel. You need to prove to yourself by going to the resources
that I have it right, And if you find out that I don't, please let me know.
This next email question came from a listener who asked to remain anonymous, and it asked
this question: Is the border review or scout master conference a test for the scouts next rank?
I asked because we recently were discussing requirements with a scout that he had had signed
off and he didn't seem to know anything about them. He didn't even have a clue in some instances.
So we talked to the scout who signed off his requirements and he didn't seem to know much
either. We found this kind of upsetting And so, to prevent this from happening again,
we have instituted a couple of new policies For scout master conferences. we have a two week
program. The first week the scout meets with senior scouts and an assistant scout master
to test his knowledge of the requirements, And the next week he meets with the scout master,
who's certain that the scout knows all his skills. The other policy that we've instituted in our
troop is to get a requirement signed off. A scout needs to have them signed off by an
older scout and either the scout master or assistant scout master. Now this seems to be
working pretty well, but I've been reading some BSA literature and it seems that we're doing things
incorrectly. So I'm asking for your read of the situation and any advice you might provide us.
Well, I would imagine that you've been reading the Guide to Advancement 2013. And you'll
read early on in that guide that no council, committee, district, unit or individual has the
authority to add to or subtract from the advancement requirements. And what you're doing is
wrong because you're adding requirements by adding steps to what should be pretty straightforward
things right Now. you've done this in all good conscience, with a laudable goal: to address
concerns about the quality of a scout's skills during the review process, But in doing that,
you've missed a couple of important points And to clarify this, let's look at the Guide to
Advancement. When we look at the Guide to Advancement, it's time to get a pencil and paper,
because here's the numbers right: 4.2.3.5 is titled the Unit Leader or Scout Master Conference,
And in part it says this quote: the conference is not a retest of the requirements on which
a scout has been signed off. It is a forum for discussing topics such as ambitions and life
purpose goals for future advancement and also for obtaining feedback on the unit's program.
Then we move to section 8.0.1.1, which is entitled not a retest or examination, And it says this
quote: though one reason for a border review is to help assure the scout did what he was
supposed to have done to meet the requirements, it shall become neither a retest or examination
nor a challenge of his knowledge. A badge recognizes what a young man has done towards
achieving the primary goal of personal growth. It is thus more about the learning experience
than about the specific skills he's learned. Now you tell me you've come up with a new policy
requiring scouts to have a requirement signed off twice, and that's adding to the requirements-
right, Something that's expressly forbidden by the Guide to Advancement. And you've instituted another
policy where he's pretested on everything before Scout Master's Conference. Again,
you've added to the requirements, and that's not allowed. The concept that fixes all this is
pretty simple. You're just aiming at the wrong thing. We don't retest the scout's skills,
because scouting isn't about the skills. It's about the growth the scout has experienced
in learning and demonstrating the skills. In other words, our aim is not to train scouts to
become skilled outdoorsmen, but to give them a set of experience to develop their character.
All of the activities and learning around the skills has this ulterior motive.
In Scout Master Conferences and Boards of Review we've learned how well we're doing
in developing the scout's character and if we're having a positive effect on him,
Not whether or not he remembers how to tie a square knot. So I'm not asking you to take my
word for this or telling you my opinion. It's what you've seen for yourself in your own reading of
the Guide to Advancement. What I suggest is getting the Guide and having all the adults
involved in the troop to sit down, read the Guide and especially concentrate on those
sections that bear on the questions that you've asked, and you should be able to clear things up.
I think that your goal is laudable, but you're just aiming at the wrong thing
And this challenge is a basic assumption that scouting is all about developing specific
skills and testing them. but it's not. We're aimed at something far greater,
and when we understand that, things start to make sense.
I heard from Sam McCulloch, who's with Cub Scout Pack 91 in Shreveport, Louisiana,
and he said this: I want our weeblos dens to operate as close as possible to a Boy Scout
Patrol. They choose a patrol name and they elect a patrol leader. but I want to kick it up a
notch. I want them to have patrol boxes and gear and have them responsible for it,
have them cook and clean up as a patrol and do everything like scouts do it.
Now am I getting too extreme? weeblos feels a little like purgatory sometimes because we're
in between the simple things that the younger cubs enjoy and we're not able to do the full
blown adventure that a scout troop does. Well, Sam, purgatory is really an interesting
allegory for weeblos. Now, before I start answering your question about kicking it up a
notch, let's have a good understanding of the specifics of weeblos camping. Have you
got all that information? And another big issue is age appropriateness. What's going on
in the broader life of weeblos during those years? How are we supposed to be working with
the weeblos years And what's your relation with the local scout troop? That might help
sort things out a little bit too. Well, Sam got back in touch and he says: well,
your question about my understanding of the specifics of weeblos camping
sparked my curiosity and I did some research And I found this in the outdoor leadership
skills for weeblos leaders. Each step in the outdoor program should be age
appropriate, with a foundation for the next higher step. We should guard against
using outdoor activities. what will take away from a boy's later experience in a
troop? We want to wet their appetite for scouting, not to give them the whole
meal too early before they're ready. Sam said I believe you've led me in the
right direction. Maybe, instead of my previous idea, just showing them how
to properly use the equipment and a couple of den overnighters would be
much more suited to the program. Well, Sam, I hardly need to add anything to that.
I can go on and on about age appropriateness, but I think you caught the idea.
We're not keeping weeblos from all these great experiences because they're ready
for them and we just do it to delay them unnaturally because of the program.
No, we're doing it because they aren't actually ready to do them yet
And unless you have some experience with older scouts, this can be a little
hard to understand. You know, when you're working with a group of weeblos
you go: Hey, why not? My weeblos are definitely ready, My son is definitely
ready to do this stuff, but you'll find out that they aren't and it's not
in their best interest. So let's get over the idea of weeblos purgatory.
Okay, we're not unnaturally, you know, punitively withholding all the
good stuff because that's only for scouts. What they're doing in
weeblos is building on age appropriate activities that
prepare them for scouts, certainly, But there's a lot of fun and
learning and personal development that goes on in weeblos
And we're going to miss that if we're looking too far ahead. Hey, if you've got
a question for me, you can get in touch. It's pretty easy to do
And you're going to find out how to do that in just a moment.
Well, thanks for listening to this 261st edition of the Scoutmaster podcast.
Here's how to keep in touch. Read the blog at scoutmastercgcom
and subscribe to receive updates to the blog by email.
You can join the thousands of other mobile scouts who have the Scoutmaster
CG app on their mobile devices- And you can get the app now,
Thank goodness- On Google Play or in the iTunes app store.
You can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom through the vast
panorama of social media outlets. Join the 7400,
join the 8200 folks who like Scoutmaster blog on Facebook.
tweet along with the chorus of 1200 tweeters on Twitter.
pin the Pultritudinous Pictures, profit publicly with 1900 other prolific
printers on Pinterest. watch us at Scoutmaster CG on YouTube
or join the 400 odd folks who form the exclusive Scoutmaster CG circle
on Google+. Now look, if you can't face Facebook, if Twitter makes you better, if
you've no interest in Pinterest, if you don't put the? U in YouTube,
if you're a minus when it comes to Google+, well, that's all right.
Zoom into the late 90s and fire off an email. You can get in touch with me,
Clark Green at C-L-A-R-K-E at ScoutmasterCGcom.
It's Clark at ScoutmasterCGcom. I take this opportunity to remind you that
everything at ScoutmasterCGcom- on the blog and the podcast-
are not endorsed, sponsored or official publications of any
scouting organization, especially the Boy Scouts of America.
I'm sure they have much better things to do with their time. It's just me
talking into a microphone trying to lend a hand to scout leaders and having a
little bit of fun along the way. and speaking of fun,
here's the man who started it all, our founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pell.
Sir Robert, Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir, Until next time, everyone.